have always been drawn to Japanese
culture a culture truly modern a steeped
in tradition the spiritual and the city
living side by side two worlds colliding
my name is andreas Renee DS and I'm a
food blogger I've always wanted to go to
Japan sampled the Japanese life in food
I'm heading to Kyoto for a very special
experience I heard about an artist who
runs a restaurant in the mountains
ataxia Kobayashi autumn oozmas Soriano
Oh comida Marie
Toma attraction schmira choic a discrete
amo così sins mo legit economist
the Cheyenne restaurant in our Oceania
cannot be reached by traditional means
the Shorin sits on the edge of a
mountain overlooking the river
the only route to the restaurant is a
high flood forest
kill attacks on yoga so stay pranic Toto
ponytail so Amano moto-meter paparizou
Toshiba anastomose
the shrine promises to entertain its
guests five senses the journey is a
transformative experience from one world
to another there really is something
magical about this place
oh no Nihal no dent Oh Tecna tottemo No
kenta-kun so Asiata so stomata a soap no
tsubasa sekai de luna stony as ever Tita
dr. Thomas
estan oh so no kakera Tati Noboru Ianto
Chikara hacer para nada todo KOICA
Vittorio's kyoho
ayah surah at ñ so de autobús Ted
attacks no chemo hacerte sallekhana Gina
the fieriness
Kokua and Helsinki right even with still
Thomas
I mean no peeping and because it daddy I
Oh Dena sonsaku Jamie Sierra taco
Coco lo voy a hacer en esta so do tedamy
Ochoa's
I miss the guy at the
like waking from a dream
retirement is Ryan with kobayashi-san
feels like a decent food
there are some secrets I'll always keep
you